sí muy buenos días raúl como dices fue
una reunión extraordinaria que arrancó a
las nueve de la noche y en la que se
pudo ver claramente la tensión entre
rusia y ucrania el embajador ruso ante
las naciones unidas dijo que la decisión
que había tomado vladimir putin de
reconocer estas zonas separatistas no
había sido de repente era necesaria para
proteger a sus habitantes dijo también
que no querían un baño de sangre y que
seguían abiertos a la diplomacia para
resolver el conflicto de ucrania sin
embargo el representante de ucrania le
respondió que rusia no quiere la paz que
eso no es cierto dijo que las fronteras
internacionalmente reconocidas de
ucrania no van a cambiar que están en su
terreno y que no tienen no tienen miedo
a nada ni a nadie además el
representante de ucrania pidió también
ante las naciones unidas que los
miembros le digan a rusia que den marcha
atrás en esa decisión de reconocer las
zonas separatistas que se vuelva a
sentar a la mesa de diálogo y que retire
sus tropas e interesante también la
intervención de china que lejos de
condenar explícitamente esta decisión de
vladimir putin como hicieron al resto de
miembros dijo que cualquier conflicto
internacional debe resolverse de manera
pacífica siguiendo los principios de la
carta de las naciones unidas
hablemos ahora entonces de la respuesta
de occidente y también por supuesto de
eeuu
si la embajadora de eeuu que por cierto
estamos muy pendientes también raúl de
que la casa blanca imponga nuevas
sanciones a largo del día de hoy a rusia
pues bien la embajadora de eeuu dijo que
no tiene ningún sentido que rusia diga
que ha enviado estas tropas a ucrania
para mantener la paz dice que saben
perfectamente lo que son a la por parte
de las potencias occidentales condenaron
los hechos apoyaron a ucrania dijeron
que las actuaciones de vladimir putin no
van de acuerdo a las naciones unidas y
además dijeron también que están
buscando una resolución pacífica a este
conflicto escuchamos también al
representante de francia que dijo que la
decisión de vladimir putin es ilegal y
que además deja a un lado cualquier
opción para el diálogo para la
negociación y también alemania dijo que
hasta ahora rusia había dicho que no que
no participaba de este conflicto pero
que con esta decisión se ha
desenmascarado
tensión internacional la que se vive
entonces mamen en torno a todo este
conflicto ante rusia ucrania y occidente
gracias entonces por el deporte desde la
gran manzana feliz esto